president Trump's feud with an
influential Republican senator could
complicate his push for tact cuts the
president today will go to an Air
National Guard base in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania to sell his plan many and
the artists will be truckers major
Garrett is at the White House with the
prospects for the first major federal
tax overhaul in decades
major good morning good morning if this
were to happen a big across-the-board
cut in federal taxes it would constitute
a huge legislative victory as the
president approaches the end of his
first year in office but his insistence
on provoking the ire of fellow
Republicans especially those in the
Senate well to state the obvious that
complicates things I'm giving the
largest tax cuts in the history of this
country in addition to that they'll be
reformed President Trump is now putting
lower taxes ahead of a simpler tax code
but his ongoing spat with Tennessee
Republican bob corker could jeopardize
even this less ambitious plan corker is
one of 50 Republican votes needed to
pass a budget and then cut taxes with
just 52 republicans total the margin is
narrow corker had already threatened to
vote against across-the-board tax cuts
if they increase the deficit if it looks
like to me chuck we're adding one penny
to the deficit I am NOT going to be for
it the president was asked if his fight
with corker will slow him down I don't
think so I think we're well in a way
it's very the people of this country
want tax cuts but mr. Trump knocked
corker again even as he garbled the
facts the failing New York Times said
little bob Corker up by recording his
conversation mr. Trump wrote was made to
sound a fool and that's what I am
dealing with as the audio recording
released by The Times makes clear corker
asked to have his interview recorded I
am so that his sharp criticism of the
president could not be misconstrued
we were on the wrong path before we're
on the right path right now believe me
that was a reference to North Korea the
focus of continuing economic and
diplomatic pressure despite the
president's repeated rhetorical
references to military option now top
officials here say that economic
sanctions and diplomatic isolation are
for the first time beginning to take
hold and genuinely squeezing the regime
in North Korea
Noora Noora major thank you so much